so i'd like to talk about this
conceptual framework
disruptive ideas startup companies and
open innovation sounds like a great
collection of things
so a disruptive idea
which is usually called a disruptive
innovation
i avoid the term innovation here because
innovation is used in two different
senses it's used
for the process by which you develop
a new product and bring it to market
it's also used for
the new thing that you bring to market
itself so
in this sense the new thing is is
somehow disruptive it
creates a new market or a new value
network
usually by selling something to a new
group of people
but it also eventually disrupts
an existing market or value network
um it may displace
an existing product it may displace an
existing industry
it can cause a major change in a supply
chain
um this is there's a lot of literature
on this but it really goes back to the
work of professor clayton christensen at
harvard
so he talked about disruptive
innovations
so good disruptive innovation going on
right now
smartphone cameras
all right interesting thing about
is that although there were all kinds of
experiments by ericsson and in the
united states and elsewhere
in the 1990s the first time
a mobile carrier offered a phone with a
camera in it
was j phone in the year 2000
that doesn't seem like that long ago j
phone
is was a japanese mobile carrier
and they're now they were bought by
vodafone
the english company and then they were
bought by uh
softbank so they started all of this
and the early phones were pretty low
quality
compared to the compact cameras even the
point-and-shoot cameras that you could
get on the market
um but they had connectivity
they were connected to your telephone
right and they were really convenient
there was a there's an old story about
what is the best camera the one that you
have with you
so they were convenient as
the smartphone appeared with a standard
operating system and also
downloadable applications they got a lot
more
useful cell phone cameras got to be a
lot more useful
especially for things like photo sharing
another economic point is that the cost
of the camera is bundled into the cost
of the phone
you really don't have a choice of
different cameras with an apple iphone
right
you get what they put in it there have
been
major improvements in the camera
functionality itself
since those early years but they were
popular from the very beginning
cell phone cameras were popular from the
time they were introduced
but now you can get a cell phone camera
with a 41 megapixel image sensor
which is sort of astounding to me
but the disruptive nature of this
innovation
is not just how good the technology has
gotten
the disruption is really against
point-and-shoot cameras
when i prepared for this you should see
the articles that came out since about
last year
of how smart smartphone cameras
are the death knell for sounding the
death knell
for point and shoot cameras or compact
cameras
their sales fell by 30 in 2011
and national geographic and the consumer
electronics association pointed out that
of all of the images taken in the united
states
were with camera phones in 2011 and
that's expected to rise to 50 percent by
2015.
that's a pretty big disruption of the
existing camera industry
now it's true that the big
high-end uh slr digital cameras
are still growing well they grew about
40 that market grew about 30 percent
last year
but to quote the guardian canon and
nikon should pay heed
or risk sequestering themselves in the
ultra high-end camera ghetto
so this is a classic example
of a disruptive innovation you've got a
creation of a new technology for a
new market or a customer base then
you've got performance
improvements in the new device which
often started out at a lower level
than existing products and that is now
disrupting or displacing some earlier
product in market
often this involves new firms taking
over an industry
or new kinds of industry structures like
new supply chains
so
interesting point
were automobiles a disruptive innovation
and this goes back to work by
christensen the actual invention of the
automobile was not particularly
disruptive
it didn't really replace the horse and
carriage at first
the car started in what the 1880
something
until the model t ford was invented
in 1920 something or other
there really wasn't much disruption of
existing transportation industries
but because the model t was lower price
and mass produced
that's when people basically started
traveling around in a different way what
did the model disrupt the model t
disrupt
horse-drawn carriages okay also
city street you know street cars used to
be all over the place they dropped like
a rock after the introduction of the
telephone rail transportation in general
some people argue that the reason rail
transportation in the u.s has gone down
is because of the interstate highway
system
which is the disruptive innovation the
highways of the cars
it also disrupted most of the early
automobile companies
there were dozens of them that failed
because ford took over the market
and so really yes it was disruptive in
a number of different ways
a couple of other more recent disruptive
innovations
first of all online advertising i think
this is
fascinating because online advertising
is taking the business away from
traditional
newspaper ads magazine ads tv
commercials
there's a clear sucking away of that
business the newspapers
are in real trouble right but the other
thing
is this online advertising is at the
center
of a whole new supply chain
now the price of an advertisement
on the internet can be optimized
change meaning changed right
once every 100 milliseconds
real-time bidding is a hot new feature
of the advertising industry one of the
reasons that this works
is you've got people on the demand side
who will aggregate all of the requests
for advertisements
by different companies that want to have
their ads up on the internet
and the demand side platforms
will guarantee not only that you get to
a certain size audience
they will guarantee who you get through
to it's much more personalized than ever
before
they want you to get to the influencer
who will really encourage other people
to buy
your product on the supply side
there are other aggregator companies
that
basically aggregate all of the
publishing space that's available
this is kind of like the old advertising
agency
business but they're doing it online and
they will then maximize the kind of
price that those companies can get
through this real-time bidding process
so you have a very new supply chain
built up around this thing
online retailing is really changing
the um the regular old retail businesses
right not only is it cutting into sales
of the brick and mortar stores but it's
changing the way that all
retailers do business how many
regular old stores like safeway
are sending you emails right emails
or have loyalty coupons of some sort
that you can download on your cell phone
or whatever
this is we're in the middle of
a really huge transformation of a number
of industries
this past year in may 2013 mackenzie
global institute set out a 150 page
book of the 12 disruptive innovations
that are going to
change the way the world works and
these 12 disruptive innovations are
things like 3d printing
genomic technologies so on and so forth
but they predict that these 12
disruptive innovation areas will be
the source of 33 trillion
dollars of new value by
the year 2025
the total world gdp
in 2025 is predicted to be 100 trillion
dollars
right now it's about 50 or 60. so
this is uh you know very
interesting kind of things to stay
involved with
now startup companies are a great
source of disruptive innovations
all companies have to innovate
if you don't innovate somebody else eats
your lunch pretty quickly
um even you know things like car
companies or retail industries are
always coming up with new kinds of sale
promotions
new models slight new you know
variations on how the store looks
all all businesses have to innovate
there are two big risks in innovation
the first risk is that you might not be
able to deliver what you're trying to
develop
that has been called technology risk
that was the term that christensen used
there's another risk and that is that
even if you develop it
nobody's going to want to buy it that's
the market risk
if you are a big company
you can spend an awful lot of money
developing a major new
technology for an existing market
and companies do so honda motor this
year
is delivering hondajet a small
business jet for about six people that
has
all kinds of new performance
characteristics and looks pretty neat
but the business jet market
is relatively well known they were able
to predict how many airports they could
get this thing into
they were able to justify
putting dozens of years of work and
hundreds of people
onto a project like this similarly
if you've got a relatively
well-known existing technology you can
spend an
awful lot of marketing money developing
a new market for it
so what did apple really do with the
iphone
it's a combination new combination of
existing technologies
in fact even the smartphone already
existed before apple started to develop
the iphone
but they put their brand behind it they
put their resources behind
it and
did pretty well with it if however
you're creating a new technology
and creating a new market right or
creating a new technology for a new
market
typically a big company can't
incubate a technology like an idea like
that for a long time
it's going to start out outside a big
company
so look at tesla motors before tesla
came along with the roadster
other companies had been playing around
with
electric cars for existing markets
the around town market tesla motors
comes up with the idea
of a high performance electric sports
car
okay that's hard development but it's
also
very risky who in the world would want
one
why would i want an electric sports car
you know you first of all you have to
convince me that it really does
outperform a porsche and second i really
miss the sound of the gears changing
right so that is a classic case
of a disru a new major innovation that
started out
in a startup company uh
facebook was that way facebook was
really okay an interesting kind of
tweaking of the technologies to make
everything work
and also a big question about how in the
world you make money with it
for the first few years of facebook i
really did not understand how they were
getting revenue
um so in any case
uh it's not the creation of the
invention
in silicon valley so often we focus on
the beginning stages of this
we focus on entrepreneurship and how
important it is to create a new idea
but if you really look at the valley
it's
not the creation
of the thing that makes it disruptive or
high value
it's the pattern of growth
in this book by mckinsey global
institute
they say that they would define
disruptive innovations based on the
ultimate size of the market
the potential for reaching hundreds of
millions or billions of people
the impact of the new technology on
multiple industries
the impact on an economy itself what
percentage of an economy is likely to be
involved with that new
area of technology they also talked
about the transformative effect
that a new technology that really
changes the supply chain of an industry
or changes the people the way that
people live or work
would have a uh you know would be
a candidate for a disruptive technology
they took a hundred candidate technology
areas and and selected 12 for this uh
for this study that they did um
so you'll hear us talk about the term
value chain
this quarter a value chain is similar to
a supply chain
in that it's an interlinked set
of activities that are necessary to
deliver a product to a market
um so the classic elements of
a supply chain system design then you've
got component design and component
manufacturing
then you've got final assembly then
you've got distribution
finally you've got sales and none of
that means anything for value
until somebody buys it so the point of a
value chain
is to start with the final purchase and
see how the revenue is divided upstream
who gets the profits out of this
at particular nodes in the supply chain
where are you going to find heavy
competition so that the
buying firm can negotiate
narrower profit margins for these
suppliers and
where are you really dependent on one or
at most two suppliers
who can negotiate a better deal with you
that kind of dynamic goes into value
chain
um there are really two ways to create a
new
uh major new value chain you can start
for nothing from nothing and create a
new industry
or you can transform some existing value
chain
including the value chain of another
industry
in history of silicon valley
we've seen a number of these new
industry value chains
in fact the whole history of the valley
looks like
a series of big waves
where you've got some sort of an
innovation
and i call all of these disruptive
innovations you can argue
whether it's disruptive of an existing
industry or not
but around some new innovation a new
industry grew
and every industry that grew
had some rising star
coming out in silicon valley that became
a world
leader in that industry you really want
to know why silicon valley is famous
it's not because
17 000 startup companies are created
here every year
it's because there are two or three
gigantic
important startup companies that really
become world leaders out of each one of
these
kinds of you know new industry waves
so if you look at some of these
superstar companies
you find that at the beginning
of sales it's all over the place growth
is all over the place
but by the fifth year of sales
they have settled down to
about 100 percent a year growth
if you take this out for another five
years
in their first 10 years of sales
these companies averaged around a
hundred
percent growth each year
that managing that kind of growth
is not really taught in business schools
i'm not
sure how teachable it is because every
case
it's it's managing chaos it's crazy
um you've got 50 employees this year
and you'll have 250 next year and you'll
have 350 the year after that
and suddenly you're in five markets when
last month you were only in one
this kind of growth is incredibly
explosive now only a few companies ever
achieve this kind of
result of course they do become the
model that everybody pays attention to
you know we're living on the post
twitter
sort of good feeling right now right but
the economic success of the valley as a
whole
is not just from these companies
the north nvca north american venture
capital association
this past year reported that there were
460 exits
of companies this is where the founders
can sell their
uh the founders and the investors in the
company can sell their stock to somebody
else of those 450-something exits
that they considered to be successful
the investors got a good return on their
cash
about 90 of them were through
acquisitions by a big company
10 of those were through ipo
now in silicon valley every year
about 17 000 companies are created about
000 either die or move away to where
it's cheaper
so of these 7 000 companies
you've got you know a goodly number of
companies that
are exiting by means of being acquired
so this means that we ought to look at
how the big companies play a part in the
silicon valley system
from the standpoint of a big company you
have to have a pipeline of innovation
you can't live on one innovation forever
you've got to introduce new products and
services to market once in a while
most of the new ideas that you have
are never going to see the market a
company will
only take the ones to market that have
the best prospects for success
and that are the best fit to the
company's overall strategy
this means that the further away from
the market you are
the more you have to really consider a
wider range of possibilities
it's fascinating companies spend 90
percent
of their r d budget in development only
about 10 percent
in applied research and basic research
and
yet you have to look at even more
possible ideas further out
so that you don't get stuck in a corner
with your
competitors in a place where you want to
be
the traditional solution was to have a
big company with a big
r d group so this kind of closed
innovation system was why
at t bell labs was so
distinctive ibm research was very
distinctive
but for the last 20 years
companies have figured that this is not
sufficient to sustain their pipelines of
innovation
they are actively looking for knowledge
and ideas from
outside the firm and
for the ideas that they're not going to
use in their own business
they spin it out so that they get some
revenue from other people using it
this much is is pretty well known this
is this open innovation framework
professor cheeseborough over at berkeley
is the most famous person in regard to
the study of open innovation
um but to take it beyond what
i had seen in his work there is a
natural
division of labor depending on how far
away you are from the market
and it's fascinating to see how
companies manage
open innovation in a way to optimize
return and risk
google we did a study of google in 2011
the size of their company internal r
d was 6.2 billion dollars
that was 13.1 percent of their revenues
that year
and incidentally the software industry
averages 13.3 percent
so it's a little hair less than the
average
amount spent on r d by a software
company
now google made one big
company acquisition in 2011 they bought
motorola mobility
that's not really an innovation play
motorola had all i'm sorry google had
already announced the android phone
and they desperately needed motorola's
uh
patent portfolio to protect and support
their phones that was a current market
play
so i kind of excluded from the
innovation thing
motorola bought 24 startup companies
in the year 2011.
these startup companies are in things
like e-commerce
platforms and e-commerce promotion video
recognition
security interesting thing is they were
areas of business that were obviously
critical to google's overall strategy
but not really part of their current
business
we estimate based on the numbers that
were reported
that google probably spent 0 600 million
or 700 million dollars
total on those 24 companies now we don't
really have figures on how many
technologies they licensed
one of the problems with doing this kind
of analysis is that there's a lot of
things that people don't say on the
surface
further out maybe three to seven years
in the future
google invested about 100 million
dollars
through google ventures it's corporate
venture capital arm
and they have increased the amount of
investment
that google ventures does every year to
300 million dollars
in 2013. now if you're doing venture
capital investing
you're only buying a minority stake
in a startup company you're not buying
controlling interest
although yeah venture capitalists can be
pretty controlling
anyway you're buying a minority stake in
something because you think it
might be very important for you
but you're not committed enough to buy
the whole thing later if these uh
you know start-up companies that they
did vc and if those companies
ideas really start to look like they
need them they may buy the rest of the
stock in the company
even further out yes google supports a
lot of good university research is there
anybody from google here
okay because i can't get a good number
on how much university research
i looked around at what they're doing at
stanford i looked at what they're doing
that they
tell you about at mit and at some of the
other places
my guess is that google spent about 20
million dollars
in university in sporting university
research
so the distinctive thing about
university research support
is that the companies have very little
control over what happens here
right academic freedom's a big deal
around here
so what you see is you see most of the
money spent here
and the further out you are they spend
less money
and have less control but they really
want to see
a broader range of ideas so
this is kind of the way that open
innovation works around here
google is a good example now for years
cisco systems was so famous for open
innovation
that people claimed that it did not have
r
d it had a d acquire and develop
strategy that's kind of unfair because
they were spending five billion dollars
on their company internal r d
um anyway why does an established big
company do this
i want to make very clear that this is
very different from outsourcing
with outsourcing the big company knows
pretty much exactly what it wants and it
pays
somebody else to develop it either
because they're cheaper than doing it
in-house
or because they have some sort of
special capabilities that you don't need
to develop in-house
so that's outsourcing open innovation is
much more
opportunistic you're trying to increase
the number of new ideas that are getting
into your innovation pipeline
you're letting others pay for incubating
that
idea until you reach some sort of an
interesting
optimization point
you're going to optimize
risk to a minimum level and return to a
maximum level
and price to as the third axis on this
so that at the right time you buy
something from outside the company or
you acquire it through licensing or you
you know partner with it different kinds
of open innovation
involve different types of relationships
the most important part of open
innovation is that
companies use it to access different
types of ideas than you can
easily incubate inside the big company
you want something different from
outside than what your people are doing
inside
um you know if you show the kind of
reduction in risk
you can see how the venture investors
start out
with a startup company that's creating a
new market and developing a new
technology
and as people actually see they may have
a working prototype
that could perform at a certain you know
cost level yeah they become a much
better candidate for
acquisition as
people start to play with beta versions
of this new device or whatever
the market risk goes down they become a
much better candidate for
acquisition um
but it's really hard to develop a
disruptive idea
inside the big company and by that i
mean
it's really hard to continue
incubating something when people
other people in the management see it as
possibly cutting
into an existing business
when it's the right time you can buy it
but it's really hard to incubate it
inside
usually a sales division will not allow
something from r d to persist
if it's going to cut into their existing
sales christensen noticed this
in his theory of disruptive innovation
he noticed that
really how did he say it
much customer focus will prevent you
from developing a new product
uh and the the famous quote behind this
goes back to the example of the
automobile henry ford
said if i had asked what my cust if i
had asked my customers what they wanted
they would have told me a faster horse
so it's really hard to come up with
something disruptive
inside the company it's really only
possible when you've got the personal
attention of the ceo
that may explain a lot of what happened
at apple right
but big companies need to deliver
disruptive ideas once in a while
otherwise their existing business lines
are going to top
out the top of the s-curve happens
and while you're trying to sustain your
existing business line
somebody's going to come along and do it
cheaper
or have a disruptive innovation from
another
angle that will disturb what you're
doing so
as a big company manager you must always
consider
that your ex your experience
has limits things will come along in the
future that you may not expect
the secret of managing open innovation
is to be able to take advantage of those
opportunities
at the right time so the big companies
are seeking disruptive ideas from the
outside
um now
so much for the conceptual framework
let's talk a little bit about how
disruptive ideas play into the whole
cycle of economic growth
basically disruptive ideas and open
innovation
become more important as an economy
becomes more advanced
now i'm going to show you a chart and
we'll spend some time talking about it
where following michael porter
there are three stages of economic
development
that are often distinguished i don't
like
the terms for the stages but um
they start somewhere so at the first
stage
is what um porter and also global
entrepreneurship monitor continues to
call
factor-driven economies these may be
developing economies okay the second
stage is what he calls
efficiency-driven economies and at the
third stage is what he calls
innovation-driven economies one reason i
don't like these terms
is because innovation occurs everywhere
at all stages
but a particular kind of innovation
becomes more important as the economy
becomes more advanced
so
what happens when an economy is
industrializing
thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people move to the cities
the government finally gets around to
establishing basic laws
there's a basic infrastructure that kind
of comes out
uh it's really a gold rush
and i think this is the situation we see
in china right now
it's still a gold rush to supply the
basic
primary needs of the population
you may create new industries because
there was no industry there before that
at the second stage though typically
what happens you now have some sort of
an industrial base
there's usually a labor shortage and a
capital shortage
and what happens is that
the skills of the labor force don't
quite keep up with the speed of economic
development
this means that the big companies the
existing companies
offer wonderful packages to people to
hire the best people in the
labor force this is where uh lifetime
employment came from in japan
the old days hp got its best people
ibm got its best people because they
would never leave big blue
right after this stage
while this stage is happening though the
real way that companies make
a lot of money is by opening up new
markets with their existing products
we'll see how this plays out a little
bit more the key competitive strength at
this point
is your ability to scale rapidly and yes
your efficiency and your operational
quality
however
if you can standardize an activity
it will flow to a lower
cost economy
if you can standardize some process
or some product there will always be
some place where it's cheaper that you
can make the product
even look inside the united states how
much
how many computer chips are still
manufactured
in silicon valley some specialty ones
but intel moved all of its manufacturing
out of the valley right it's in arizona
and oregon and places like that
where it's cheaper so that's one thing
there is this pressure to maintain high
wage levels
that means that you're competing against
places where the wage levels are a lot
lower
also one of the things that people do
as an economy develops is they invest
heavily in education
the difficulty of
getting rid of the car industry in
detroit
is that you can make a very high hourly
wage with a high school education
you have to be good at what you do you
really have to have the skills
but it doesn't require the kind of
critical thinking that's the
hallmark of a university education this
means
that the children of the people who are
line workers
typically are going to college and
they want a different future and their
parents kind of want them to have a
brighter future they don't want them in
the factory all day
so as wealth spreads and as higher
education
spreads throughout the population
different kinds
of competitive
aspects a competitive opportunities
appear
the real hallmark for
business opportunity in an advanced
economy is creative fresh new ideas
out of the box thinking seeing something
before the people around you see it
um
yeah this
is uh yeah i think this will come out a
little bit better if we
if we look at some more specific uh
examples
i did want to point out that you know in
the as economies develop
you run a greater likelihood
that you will cause be causing some sort
of disruption
as you develop a new idea in a factor
driven economy
it's a blank slate you're bringing in
the first set of industry
um and then you expand your business
by opening up new markets that's
relatively lower risk
right than the risk of developing a new
technology and a new market
and there is this general principle of
why should you take on any more risk
than you have to
yeah so you really need disruptive
innovations to keep an economy going
forward look at some gdp numbers
just as a kind of prelude to the next
kind of discussion
so world economy us
gdp per person is almost fifty thousand
dollars
third largest economy china is nine
thousand one hundred
now this is a ppp calculation according
to the cia world factbook
i was in korea last week giving a
kind of version of this talk to a big
conference
and i was surprised to find out that
korea which in ppp
according to the cia factbook has a gdp
of about 32
400 the official figures in korea are
still
22 000 dollars that's at the official
exchange rate
so you're really uh you know
do take these kind of as uh under
advisement
so china 9100 there's a huge amount of
regional difference
right in the east coast cities the gdp
is already
close to 13 000 or 14 000
in the interior it's a lot less india
is averaging about 3900 but there are
some islands in india we'll talk about
japan at 36 000 um south korea
at 32 000 taiwan at 38 000
and then you've got hong kong and
singapore even higher than the united
states
so what's going on okay china
is a classic factor driven economy
even though people don't use the term
developing economy for china the world
bank calls it a transitional economy
but there are huge business
opportunities just to grow things for
the domestic market
most of the economic growth until
recently
was really through investment not
through consumption
but the percentage of the economy and
consumption has been
growing drastically in the last few
years
it's relatively easy to bring something
into china that hasn't been there before
still not to disrupt an existing
industry
fascinating point is the u.s venture
capital firms
really got active going into china about
10 years ago
a lot of them brought their silicon
valley attitudes of what was a good
investment over to china
and within a year had changed their
investment strategy
they weren't investing in difficult
technology development problems
they were investing in factories that
make milk cartons
because milk consumption in china was
growing by 60 or 70 percent a year
why take the risk if you don't have to
so they had really moved into lower tech
business
ideas that come along with the evolution
of an industry or consumer demands
there are regional differences in china
that really track the us
better than just about any other country
in asia
what is happening now is a lot of
the advanced east coast
cities are now starting to compete
against the tier two cities
in the inland because labor is a lot
cheaper
land is a lot cheaper in the tier two
cities or even the tier three cities
but you do see disruptive innovations
e-commerce is really changing the way
that retailing is done in china
and we have a presentation on that later
in the series
india is
fascinating because it's got little
islands of global business
in the middle of a still early stage
developing agrarian economy but these
little islands
account for a big part of indian gdp
but if you look at how much domestic
sales
infosys and wipro does do
it's less than two percent of their
total yearly output
is to the domestic indian market so
uh in this sector this it
services innovation sector what you
really have
is companies that are competing globally
for the world
markets alongs against oracle against
sap you've got heavy competition
in world software alongside
a lot of new business ideas to develop
bottom of the pyramid businesses
bottom of the pyramid businesses are
often
a classic factor driven opportunity it
may or may not
involve disrupting some existing
industry so
last spring this spring we had two
indian companies that we featured
redbus does online bus ticket sales
and redbus disrupted existing channels
of bus ticket sales
but everybody benefited because
there was it was better information to
people
and the retailers could also have better
access to
a broader range of sales in oz the other
company that we featured
was delivering google type search using
cell phone sms
um this one was probably not really
disrupting anything
because most of the people it was
targeting did not have
access to the internet otherwise
they were able to use this service in
order to get google type search
using sms so that one i think was not
really
uh disruptive although it was a new
market
by the way redbus got acquired by a
chinese company
so i'm curious if that means that
redbus's next step is to take the idea
into the chinese market
um we'll see
moving up the line of companies
south korea is really at the cusp
of leaving the efficiency-driven economy
stage and getting into the
driven economy stage most of the
successes
of the korean economy in the last 20 or
30 years
are really korean companies taking over
world markets from
other companies like japanese companies
so
in dram right the korean companies
definitely took their market share away
from japanese companies
lcd tvs if you go back to the history of
lcds they started out in the u.s and
then the japanese took them from the u.s
and then koreans taken from the japanese
automobiles is where it's at now how
many advertisements have you seen for
hyundai
and kia lately the market growth is
dramatic
just in the last year whose market share
are they taking
okay i would have to say it's probably
toyota and nissan
cell phones so u.s motorola
and you had remember nokia yeah
and the japanese cell phone makers never
really did get outside the japanese
markets very well
but all of this is going to samsung and
lg
when you are in beijing you will see
advertisements for samsung phones
heavily
so you know basically this
did disrupt an existing industry but
they did it
with an existing technology it's a
classic efficiency play
at the beginning the korean products
were
as good but their cost performance was
better
as the companies made money to their
credit
their performance is even better
so this is great for a stage two economy
um but the korean government is already
aware that there is a limit to this
the new korean government that started
this past year
their buzzword is the creative economy
and they are trying very hard to promote
entrepreneurship
they're very hard to promote a
particular kind
of innovation which comes from internal
sources
not from copying somebody else
this is also an attempt to mitigate the
danger of a
very highly concentrated economy
the big cheval companies have
a lot of the available capital in the
korean economy
and i think that the government would
like to see this spread out
as being a more healthy way for the
economy to continue to grow
so south korea is still in the stage too
still efficiency driven but it's getting
closer and closer
i'm on the advisory board for a
startup accelerator in seoul and i was
just there last week
and there are really interesting great
ideas coming out
but the problem for korean companies
right now
is that the open innovation isn't there
the big companies don't
buy their products if they acquire the
company they usually do so to keep it
out of the market
not to really take advantage of it
so if you move on to japan
i think japan is finding its way
as an innovation-driven economy there
are some disruptive new ideas
uniqlo really changed the whole
department store scene in japan
the big department stores are still
there but they have to do business in a
different way thanks to
the discount uh business model that
uniqlo brought in
but throughout the history of japan
the really giant famous new companies
that appear
whether it's dna and gree or whether
it's softbank years before that
or way back before that panasonic honda
motors
are all companies that somehow were
first movers
in creating new industries giant new
markets
more recent examples i'm a big fan of
the the uh
slika card which is uh
probably one of the first cards that you
can use
uh in the tr to pay for your train fares
in japan it's a brilliant system
and suica is now accepted by taxi cabs
it's accepted on buses
it's also accepted in a lot of
convenience stores
is this really
disrupting an existing industry
kind of hard to see how it would be
disrupting an existing industry micro
payments didn't really happen before
that
um dna and grieve the mobile game
publishing
that was new it didn't really take
market share away from anybody else in
order to become big
softbank um they were really the first
people who
understood how to make money with shrink
wrapped software in japan
up until that time there was no market
for shrink wrap software
most companies used
business systems with custom-made
software that was part of a
specific hardware product there was no
interoperability at all
so softbank you know definitely
created something new the older bigger
firms are having trouble with open
innovation this is not unique to japan
at all but it's really hard to break
a good customer relationship
you know and as christensen said if um
you're too focused on your customer you
may miss the opportunity
um the incentives for open innovation to
r d
personnel are also not quite well
developed
taiwan i think is in slightly earlier
stages of an innovation driven economy
uh there's been this outflow of a lot of
manufacturing away from taiwan into the
mainland
a lot of the money behind it is
taiwanese money
companies are not really competing
on growth in the domestic taiwan market
there's a long history of science parks
shinshu science park is at least 30
years old
um there's still a strong base
of contract and component manufacturing
but it's fascinating how you see this
shift
inside the business of tsmc from
cost-based competition to manufacturing
excellent based competition
to customer service based competition
and professor howe lee and and sun jin
huang
here at stanford's jsb wrote this up in
a fascinating case study
you do still see stage two kinds of
things
just last week uh hong hai precision
industry
announced that they're going to form a
jv to sell
cell phones in indonesia okay great
expansion
um
now hong kong and singapore which
actually have higher gdp
per person than the u.s does are really
investment driven economies
they're urban economies and there are
some characteristics of being innovation
driven
you do have strong r d institutions
you've got you know good universities
and research centers
um the entrepreneurial activities there
do focus more on entrepreneurship of
opportunity than on
entrepreneurship and necessity people
decide to be an entrepreneur
because they think that's the best way
for them to have an impact not because
they can't get a job in an existing
company
um economic growth is really a function
of
a lot of external investments in other
asian markets
but some innovation services are very
strong
hong kong and singapore both try to sell
themselves as places to put your ip
before you go into china still the case
that top students are aiming for jobs in
financial industries and government more
than they're aiming for entrepreneurial
careers
and yet the governments are working to
promote innovation and entrepreneurship
the us has really grown over the last uh
30 years in regard to entrepreneurial
innovation
which really means open innovation right
because the big companies buy the output
in 1981 large firms accounted for 70
percent
71 of all corporate spending on r d
in the u.s that number had dropped to
38 by the year 2005. now i don't want to
say that big companies have stopped
spending on r d
in absolute dollar numbers
the growth in r d spending
among companies big companies in the u.s
was almost four times during this time
period the
point is that small firms and
medium-sized firms
grew even more grew even faster
so that they now take up you know almost
a quarter of
all of the r d spending is on these
firms
sure enough smaller firms are accounting
for
you know a much higher percentage of
american patents than they used to
what does this really show it shows
people are
desperate and are spending a lot of
money on what they think will be
disruptive innovation
it's the venture investors who are
funding this
so the big companies want to buy it when
they can buy it instead of incubating it
in-house
in comparison
open innovation still lags in asia
i could only get numbers from japan and
south korea
but the percentage of patents
filed in the u.s filed by small
entities individuals and small firms
was 36 percent in the u.s now that's
probably skewed on the high side
because if you're in the u.s it makes
sense to file in the u.s
if you're in a foreign country you only
file in the u.s
if you think that your patent is worth
paying the extra money to file in the
u.s for
so if you look at the rest of the oecd
excluding the u.s
26 percent of the patents filed in the
u.s
were by small entities but japan only
4.4 percent of the patents filed were by
small entities
of the patents filed in the u.s were
filed by small entities south korea 14.4
um so some
non-u.s countries have a much higher
percentage i was fascinated to find out
that
52.4 of us
patents that came from israel were filed
by
small entities so uh
certainly israel is is focusing on this
entrepreneurial innovation
um where do we go from here
i want to examine some potentially
disruptive innovations that we see
coming from asia economies
and really explore whether these new
value chains are
indicating an increase in open
innovation or not
so we'll let industry speak for itself
next week we've got a panel discussion
of new platforms for
data-driven analysis and we've got the
ceo
of crowd analytics which is fascinating
they take analytic problems from
companies
and crowdsource them to a community of
data scientists
great play but certainly a play for the
world market
and the other company is algorithms io
which has won an award here
in silicon valley they have
a kind of modularized platform for easy
to develop
custom analytics
in a couple of weeks we'll look at
nanoelectronics have a presentation by a
new industry consortium coming from
japan
on the 24th of this month we've got
a presentation that i think will be on
data driven marketing
it's definitely coming from sk planet
which is uh
kind of a big you know online
advertising company in
korea we've got a presentation on
hydrogen
energy storage we've got a presentation
on water resource management
and we've got a presentation on
e-commerce and retailing so i think
it'll be a fun quarter
we'll see what industry says for itself
and
i hope that today was useful in regard
to seeing the
whole kind of conceptual framework i'd
be happy to take questions for a few
minutes
thank you ed
richard i'm curious um there's a theory
in silicon valley that there's a special
or secret saucer
secret sauce yeah it's very difficult to
export it but you're talking about
trends and moving from you know group
two to group three
economies um what is the time period
that you think it's gonna take for some
of the advanced
asian economies the so-called asian
tigers turn from the 90s
to sort of say catch up to silicon
valley and do you think that
innovation is still going to continue
here
i think that it doesn't happen at a
regular continuous pace
i think you see jumps uh i think that
a few success stories in some of the big
asia economies will really change the
mood there rather quickly i think that
there's
always a danger innovation is risky it's
a
riskier basis for corporate growth and
you have to use that basis for corporate
growth in an advanced economy
you don't have to use it so much if
you're cheaper than other people and you
can do
good manufacturing um
but i don't think that the silicon
valley system will break
the reason i say that is because we have
so many different areas of technology
here
just the pure scale of silicon valley is
bigger than
anywhere else i've seen i do think that
if you look over the next 50 to 100
years you'll see
a kind of clustering into these urban
centers of innovation like silicon
valley we've already seen a number of
them grow up in the rest of the u.s
you know and and okay boston
massachusetts area is as old as silicon
valley is
but you'll see this developing
where the wage levels will be higher the
prices will be higher
the kind of exciting thing about china
is that the whole level is going up
but the east coast is really starting to
look like silicon valley in some ways
so in some ways a national economy
comparison of national economies
is the wrong yardstick to use uh
yeah but thanks good question go ahead
yeah
some of the market research firms are
predicting that because of shale gas
and the really lowering cost of energy
the energy-intensive products in the
factoring economies
like liquid crystal displays are going
to come back
to this country
that could happen certainly shale gas
has had a huge impact on a lot of
industries already
and i think that this is one of those
kinds of things
will never get rid of manufacturing in
the us but what makes us
manufacturing competitive it's going to
be its flexibility
it's going to be its modularization it's
going to be
being able to be more cost effective at
small batch manufacturing
right the kind of things that fit in
with these sort of
innovation skills
it's very dangerous for an economy to
lose the knowledge
that's associated with the basic level
stuff
and one of the things that i've thought
about for a long time
is that you have to keep manufacturing
in an economy to keep the knowledge base
for everything else
i saw this in the semiconductor industry
big time right
all the firms were becoming fabulous and
then all of a sudden what's the new sort
of sources of
of uh competitiveness the ability to
deal with
new advanced materials that don't fit
old standard cmos so uh
i do think manufacturing will stay tom
so i'm going to go back to that first
question kind of
just around but first of all can you go
back to that slide that
showed open innovation on the bottom and
on the top was the other set
of uh i guess like spinning out things
i just wanted to get that
yeah yeah okay so um one of the
questions the question i have is
with this open innovation to what extent
is that this this intangible human
element
that silicon valley has you have the law
firms here you have the pr firms you
have all this stuff
and there's this funny soup and somehow
things really happen out of it
and to what extent can you build a
structure
infrastructure can somebody say well
this is what we need to do to have this
if we just have all these things
you can develop a legal system but you
got to have the case law to support it
and so i do think that the knowledge
that has developed here
from doing this over the years puts us
pretty far ahead
uh there's nothing secret that can't be
you know replicated somewhere else
although every place has got to match
its own culture you know in confucian
cultures business is more relationship
based
here it's very transactional and
i think that's one reason open
innovation developed as easily as it did
in the u.s
what's the idea of an entrepreneur
starting a company here i'll grow it for
seven or ten years and make a bunch of
money
i'll give the money to my children or
i'll use the money to
you know invest in the next company uh
in
asia most entrepreneurs think that the
companies are like their children
and selling your child to somebody else
is not very
nice right so that
does make a disadvantage in this whole
open innovation
but yet there may be advantages to
having tighter relationships that you
can rely on more
we really haven't seen just how it will
play out in different economies
it will be really interesting i think
that
the scale of silicon valley and the
experience of silicon valley are by far
our biggest competitive advantages but
the good thing about the valley is you
keep
moving on to the next new thing right so
i'm i'm
confident for us as we go forward islet
yeah i met with a young entrepreneur
yesterday who
a company teaching entrepreneurship and
he told me that south korea
is apparently the government is planning
to spend mega bucks
on on that and um he he didn't
give me any details on i was wondering
if you've heard anything about that what
kind of policies
is south korea thinking of uh using here
and is that likely to be successful
there's a number of direct kind of
fiscal policies about
investing uh creating investment funds
and so forth
there's a lot to encourage groups to
develop
educational approaches
all of that's good you know and and as
someone who studies entrepreneurship i'd
love to have a little bit of it too
uh but the danger
for this is that if you don't also grow
the ability
of the company to be successful in the
market you can promote entrepreneurship
until you're blue
and you'll get a lot of frustrated young
people
you know the it's really you have to
have access to the market
and the problem is not in the creation
stage it's not in the early incubation
stage the problem is in the market stage
innovators and entrepreneurs need early
adopters
where are the early adopters or the
large companies typically
and if you don't have those if it's a
closed innovation environment
you've got a problem that's true uh if
you can
tip the scale a little bit people make
economically rational choices
and so if you tip the scale a little bit
so that if you leave the big company and
you try your own company
if that's not a one-way street out of
the mainstream
then you'll get better people trying to
build companies
but yeah you're right you need early
adopters those early adopters are in
every economy
there are wonderful entrepreneurial
young people throughout all of asia
um in korea and in japan
most of the young people are worried
about is it okay to be this way
and what happens is the classic
jeff moore break between the early
adopters
and the mass market somehow you've got
to have some success stories
that will virally spread
entrepreneurship
to the right people in the economy
there's one other thing that
entrepreneurship really needs when
people talk about silicon valley
they never talk about the people who go
to work for square
now when square's got a couple hundred
people
right it's only two or three years old
the companies that have
thirty to a thousand people in silicon
valley are
well supplied by good people in the
silicon valley labor force
but in a more traditional economy they
don't have the reputation and have a
hard
harder time getting people to work for
them it's people who are willing to
invest
their own career in a high growth
company
as well as the people who start the high
growth companies that are really
important
great comments thanks
i think we've got some oh please go
ahead comment regarding uh singapore
and hong kong are very relevant i met a
venture capitalist who's an american
originally from marin county
who is now based in singapore and when i
poked a little bit to find out why he
moved to
singapore he told me that and i don't
remember the exact figure but
whatever investment he makes for a
startup
the singaporean government matches him i
believe either five to one or
six to one so he puts in 50 000 and they
match him with another 250 or 300.
see this is one of those things that
tips the scale right yeah
and not only that but earlier this week
i was invited to a meeting where
three delegate delegates from the hong
kong government came in trying to
lure startups into hong kong sure
and and there's a lot of good stuff
going on there it's a
both of those are really exciting places
they're fascinating
they don't have the reputation of the
valley yet right
but things will change thanks everybody
we've got some refreshments outside i
hope you'll stay around
and talk to each other and i'd be happy
to talk to you informally and so forth
anybody who's a student has questions
let me know happy to talk
and look forward to seeing you again
next week thanks
you